Welcome back everyone it's charlie this will be my
full house of the dragon episode 4 trailer video
there's a whole bunch of game of thrones easter
eggs obviously some of them a little bit more
obvious than others opening the trailer with the
prophecy of the prince who was promised talking
about jon snow we had all the daenerys easter
eggs during episode 1 earlier in the series
so it's only natural that they would also start
referencing jon snow if we're going to be doing
a lot of easter eggs for what happens later in
the timeline if you're new to the channel i am
doing videos for all the episodes just like i
did for game of thrones be sure to subscribe to
get them all we're also doing a giveaway for hbo
max subscriptions too all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and post all your theories
based on the trailer footage down in the comments
careful for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far but like i said
they begin the trailer with rhaenyra reading the
prophecy of the prince who has promised aegon's
prophecy of a song of ice and fire or he calls it
a song of ice and fire but it's a prophecy about
the long night the coming of the white walkers
that they think could happen at any moment like
each new targaryen king when he learns about
the prophecy and takes the iron throne thinks
that it's right around the corner so like this
whole time viserys has been king not that long
in the grand scheme of things he's been low-grade
paranoid about the white walkers attacking at any
moment in addition to all the regular problems
he's been dealing with the last 10 years or so
i've already done a video about who knew the
prophecy at which times during the timeline like
at what point did the prophecy get lost when did
it not get passed on like what happened with the
mad king and rhaegar because rhaegar eventually
learned the prophecy but the way that george r
martin talks about the prophecy in the way
that rhaegar learned about it it sounds like
right before the events of robert's rebellion
the prophecy had been lost so when rhaegar was
learning about the prophecy he actually learned
about it because he was so fond of going through
the citadel's secret archives that were only
accessible to really highborn people like the
crown prince like rhaegar as the crown prince was
basically one of the most powerful people in the
realm so if he told the archmages of the citadel
let me into this locked room with all these secret
scrolls they would have to do it they made a big
deal about that when samwell joined the citadel
to become a maester no no you're not allowed to go
in there the other cool detail they reveal in this
trailer is that she's reading the prophecy which
has been carved or been etched into the valyrian
steel blade of the knife itself i did videos
about the actual cat's paws valyrian dagger like
way back during the game of thrones main series
episodes but the steel of the blade is obviously
valyrian steel the hilt is made of dragon bone
and the giant red jewel is just a huge ruby they
explained during episode one even though a little
over 100 years has gone by since aegon's conquest
valyrian steel at this point is incredibly rare
so all valyrian steel of any kind is very valuable
but at this time in history are more known
valerian steel blades belonging to people
some of them get lost over the years up to
the events of the game of thrones series
and the whole reason why arya littlefinger joffrey
robert baratheon anyone after rhaegar targaryen
who would have owned the knife assuming that it
probably belonged to rhaegar and the mad king
at some point and then after they sacked the red
keep during robert's rebellion all the targaryens
possessions were basically either sold off or
given to robert baratheon and that's how the
knife passed into littlefinger's possession
in robert baratheon's possession eventually
but the reason why all of those people wouldn't
have known about the prophecy of the long night
that was baked into the blade is because
they didn't think to heat the blade up
as the stairs are showing right near in the
trailer you have to heat the blade to intense
temperatures and then the prophecy will reveal
itself in the middle it's one of those cool
lore additions that george r martin helps them
make without breaking the timeline like oh this
is why nobody knew about it because they didn't
heat the blade up the whole idea that the prince
who was promised is mostly meant to be a reference
to jon snow but a lot of people like kinvara the
red temple obviously believe it's daenerys as
well the whole idea of the prophecy is that
aegon had a dragon dream that someone of his
blood he didn't know who someone of his blood
would stop the long night in both daenerys and
jon snow are of his blood because of all the
sister wiving in the targaryen family one of the
other funny details you may have recognized in the
voiceovers during the trailer is that viserys also
literally says the name of the show in the show
again ah he said the thing everybody pointing at
the screen doing the meme the funny thing is that
during episode 1 rhaenyra or the older version
of rhaenyra played by the different actress said
the exact same phrase out loud the only thing
that could tear down the house of the dragon
was itself the house of the dragon will stand
as one for a further generation we'll have to
start a counter eventually to see how many times
in the episodes somebody actually says the name
of the show itself there's an overhead shot of a
bunch of women walking through the hallway it's
the same women that helped take care of the royal
children i don't know if that has something to do
with the birth of alicent's second child because
i believe a year is supposed to have gone by like
the time jump is only about a year so it's enough
time for alicen'ts second child to be born it's a
little girl named helaena targaryen rhaenyra can
breathe a little bit easier because there's only
one male heir that she has to contend with right
now this is just the beginning though there'll be
more time jumps in a whole bunch of children on
both sides of the aisle the blacks and the greens
we see prince daemon come back to court having
been crowned king of the stepstones after the
successful campaign in the title of the episode is
actually king of the narrow sea technically that's
the term coles valerian and his men crown daemon
king of the narrow sea because the stepstones
isn't part of westeros otherwise there'd be a much
bigger problem here when he comes back to court
but the whole idea is that he left kind of in
exile made a name for himself finally successfully
defeated crab feeder in his army the triarchy so
he's trying to roll in like a boss like ah they
crown me king of the narrow sea he's even wearing
a crown that looks like it was made of bones you
also notice he's carrying crab feeders warhammer
that he used vasara seems a little bit surprised
the rest of court seems like they don't know what
to do about it and i think the way they cut the
trailer they just want to play on some of the
mystery as to what daemon's motives are what his
goals are after this because obviously he still
wants the iron throne but because it's rhaenyra
versus aegon ii at the moment that's where all the
attention is a lot of people are viewing daemon is
more of a wild card especially allison hightower
who's telling viserys in otto hightower her father
that she doesn't trust him it does seem like her
friendship with rhaenyra is slowly on the men
but they still have that voiceover during the
trailer where you hear one of the lords yelling
at other lords arguing over the succession
itself like the lords themselves are still
up in the air as to who is going to eventually
sit on the iron throne will it be the princess
rhaenyra or the young princeling aegon ii you
hear rainier arguing with her father more about
actually getting married remember it's been a year
time jump since the last episode so he's probably
getting really tired of the weight like okay
finally you have to pick someone get married now
when she's sitting here she's listening to more
of her suitors come in and try to plead their case
with her like please marry me and it's this young
boy here that's the joke like all the lords of the
realm are basically trotting out all their sons
please marry my son the baratheon that's sitting
with her while she's listening to all these
marriage proposals is boremund baratheon he's
the current lord of house baratheon that swore
the oath of fealty to her during episode 1. then
you have this scene with otto hightower talking
to viserys targaryen about this vile rumor about
rhaenyra targaryen like later if she's talking to
someone else saying how dare you accuse me of this
and i think the whole idea here is that they don't
trust daemon and they basically think that daemon
deflowered or did something sexual with rhaenyra
because you see her sneaking out of the red keep
through the monument to blaring the black dread
wearing the clothes of the commoner running
through the streets of flea bottom in the city
then a couple people in a dark alley getting it on
in what seems like a couple other people spying
on them so this is a bit of a call back to that
scene in episode 1 where otto hightower did the
same thing to daemon targaryen basically throwing
him under the bus where the king eventually chose
raniere as the successor because he was choosing
the option that was not his brother like well it
can't be my brother so rainier is the best option
so when viserys is getting pissed off about all
this spicy gossip i think that's what it's about
about rhaenyra being deflowered potentially
when you see rhaenyra sailing on the targaryen
ship with kristen cole and you see daemon and
his dragon caraxies fly by them this might be
later in the episode and she might be exiled to
dragon son or she might just be taking off to live
on dragonstone because technically as she said
during previous episodes dragonstone belongs to
her because she is the heir typically when someone
is named the heir to the iron throne they're named
either prince or princess of dragonstone like
that's a title they get and they gain possession
of dragonstone so if she wanted to she could go
live at dragonstone anytime she wants to but to
make a joke that's sort of like the targaryen
way of quitting twitter like you basically leave
court you leave the center of all politics so
you don't really find out about what's actually
happening day to day unless somebody sends you
ravens with more information so what might be
happening is that because of all the drama and the
spicy gossip here she just might be piecing out
which i think was also foreshadowed during
last week's episode with that dragon's eye
song because it was kind of a lament about how
this woman got her heart broken and left on a ship
even though he doesn't really show up during any
of this trailer footage you have the whole idea
too that laner valerian seemed like the best
option for her like lionel strong and allison
hightower both separately suggested marrying laner
velaryon the only problem with rhaenyra marrying
laner is that he's actually gay so it's kind of
like a loveless marriage but potentially it's a
way to solve a lot of her problems so if you start
getting some scenes with her and laner it might
happen during next week's episode maybe episode
5. you have to remember there's a couple big
time jumps in the next couple of episodes so like
stuff happens really quickly if you spotted any
other big easter eggs in the new trailer footage
that i didn't talk about in the video just write
them below in the comments and what i'll do is i
have a couple big bonus videos planned this week
there's also a couple other big series that are
starting like lord of the rings also started
rick and morty just started i'll be doing
episode videos for season six make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so you don't
miss any of that stuff everyone click here for
my full house of the dragon episode 3 video and
click here for all my other house of the dragon
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!